right the balla probe may be over but
the deep state is not done trying to
undermine the Trump administration over
the weekend disgraced former FBI
director James Comey ripped the Attorney
General Bill Barr saying the Attorney
General was echoing conspiracy theories
that's a joke coming from him but
meanwhile a Boston Herald columnist
points out that James Comey himself well
he has been a central figure in the
biggest conspiracy theory in modern
times namely the Russia hoax and joining
us now with reaction the Senate
Judiciary Committee chairman Lindsey
Graham you know I actually read stuff
and I have once read the new Ness report
took the time to read already the
Grassley Graham memo and you might be
familiar with that one
and it said that the bulk of the
implement the bulk of information in the
FISA application in October 2016 that
led directly to the spying of the Trump
campaign then the Trump transition team
then the Trump presidency was the
Hillary phony unverified unverifiable
Russian dossier and James Comey signed
it and in January 2017 told then
candidate Trump and Trump Tower
president electrum oh that it's
salacious but not verified the opposite
of what he said to the FISA Court now it
sounded like a crime was perpetrated on
the court by James Comey to me but what
do I know well it's not a theory we know
that that Comey told the president in a
private meeting that I want you to know
about the dossier this unverified is
salacious but I want you to know about
it and that's the same document given to
the court beginning in October where
they said under oath it was credible and
reliable to get a warrant against an
American citizen those two things don't
add up that's not a conspiracy theory
those are facts that need to be
reconciled how do you make what they did
to attorney John Dowd who was just
defending himself yeah what do you make
of Muller last week nine and a half
minutes he's everything he said
contradicted what he had previously said
about the issue of whether or not DOJ
policy
allows the consideration of an
indictment of a sitting president and
that that was a factor but he said just
the opposite to five other people on
seven other occasions well so this is
important when he met with Barr
personally months before met weeks
before the report was given out he told
Barr I can't decide about obstruction
I'm gonna let you do it but I did not
make my decision based on DOJ policy you
can't indict his sitting president I
just think the complication of the facts
and the law I'm going to turn it over to
you he never mentioned that in the news
conference and that's very important but
here's what he did in his four hundred
and something page report no collusion
with the Russians he decided not to
bring a case against the president based
on obstruction to me case closed
let's look at Comey mccabe struck page
all these other people and see how we
got into this mess to begin with
senator we now learn that all of this
special treatment and consideration was
given to Hillary Clinton you know no
recordings no 302s you allow other
people to sit in on an FBI supposedly
interrogation investigation
unprecedented then you have struck and
Paige implicating the Attorney General
as having the fix in the whole time the
same one that met with Bill Clinton on
the tarmac for forty five minutes to
talk about grant Kent's only and we know
that she violated the Espionage Act
because James Comey told us so then we
have the under law then we have the
intention of destroying the evidence
that was a subpoenaed emails how do we
how do we say we have equal justice in
this country an equal application of our
laws if she gets away with that well I
think the decision not to prosecute her
was probably most likely politically
motivated because obstruction of justice
taken a hammer to two phones being asked
for his evidence cleaning a server
bleaching it out so you can't get the
emails is classic obstruction of justice
compromising classified information she
clearly did that the decision not to
prosecute her was pretty simple in my
view if you want her to win you can't
prosecute her
well you have a big say in the senator
because you happen to be the chairman of
the powerful committee that will look
into this but we now are expected in the
Horowitz report on FISA abuse I'm not
sure exactly what John Ober is doing but
I expect we'll hear something about the
leaking aspect of all this then we've
got mr. doram who wanted to interview
Christopher Steele which I think would
be a good first step
maybe our friends the British can
extradite him which would be nice and
then we've got the Attorney General
himself who answered your questions is
Muller dead yes are you concerned about
the Hillary investigation yes he
concerned about Pfizer abuse yes he
concerned about Intel abuse yes what
should happen in your view going from
here so Horowitz will issue is report
about the FISA warrant process I will
take their report to see if we need to
change our laws to make sure it never
happens again
Durham's going to look at all these
castor characters to see if they broke
the law and bars home gonna make sure
the DOJ is reformed so it's never abused
in this way in the future my job is to
have oversight to change the laws to
protect the country from abuse in the
future Durham is looking at criminality
and bars sitting on top of all that
we're going to get to the bottom of it
for the good of the country because at
the end of the day you can't have people
enforcing the law take it in their own
hands for political purposes and by the
way all your travel and I know you're
doing great things for the country on
national security issues thank you
but you're taking away from the audience
hearing directly from you when you go
away for a week I'm just saying
can I say one thing about the border yes
doesn't Trump is right to do whatever is
necessary to stop the disaster at the
border it's not a crisis is a complete
disaster and Mexico can do better they
should do better and I support the
president in any way possible to get
Mexico to do better and I'm going to
have a vote on my bill to close the
asylum loophole and the unaccompanied
minors in two weeks count me in Thank
You senator good to see it